[Music]
Ravens home and we are in her closets
okay let's just let's jump right in
because fashion was such a big part of
That's So Raven
yes Raven Baxter is back and only et got
a peek inside the Ravens home wardrobe
department where we learned - Raven he's
still totally Raven oh this is still
Raven Baxter she's still a fashion
designer her personal style and the
style of her kids is very important but
what we love is creative we love taking
pieces out of the store and putting
things together so one of the pieces
that you're gonna be saying throughout
the entire season and so are I'm gonna
call them tricked-out onesies everybody
needs a good onesie with a butt pad
let's keep going right another piece
that we have which is actually a piece
that you yourself can find which is
really cool but the way we changed it is
we cut the sides it kind of brings back
what Raven Baxter used to do a lot in
that so Raven which was a lot of
embroidery so we're bringing it up to
you know the mother version of Raven
Baxter come on weirdest thing happened
not always about you Booker how would
you say Raven style has changed as a mom
it's a lot sleeker clean lines not so
much babe it's more like the
sophisticated bass sophisticated instead
of just salt it's truffle salt you know
I see you guys see we've stepped up our
game a little bit just check out these
shoes so with Raven Baxter on master
Raven I wore heels almost every episode
a girl got smart and stopped wearing
heels so now we have a really fun
collection of flat sneakers and also
some gems in there from an old co-star
of mine Miss Whoopi Goldberg she blessed
me with some amazing shoes your motherly
instinct has kicked in playing a mom on
TV has that been a weird for you it is
okay weird isn't the right word for me I
love it I've always wanted to be a
mother I'm still looking forward to that
day when I can but I was trying my
hardest to be as motherly as I can but
we also have a job to do so it's a
little bit of
a little bit of everything because this
is still a job we're having fun but we
have a job to do and we have to get this
show on the road so other than being a
mom how would you say Raven has changed
the character in ten years
the reason Baxter has not changed I
think Raven Baxter is still that fun
kooky crazy down for whatever here for
friends girl and still having psychic
visions oh never going away and whatever
kid sucks I get visions so we're all
good we're all good can you give us the
best psychic vision look to the camera
all right Tina Ravens closet now it's
time to see Chelsea's oh hello I mean
we're in Chelsea's closets it's kind of
fabulous in Chelsea's kind of dealing
with them there's her storyline being
that she's really rich you know and um
is sort of not anymore and kind of
living with Raven because of financial
difficulties
ah yeah so it's interesting to see her
kind of where her house clothes that
might be a nicer brand that she's kind
of you know not able to actually go out
and buy I see it's very mom chic very
mom she yes that's good very smart I
like being an only child
there's never question favoritest it's
me right looking at Chelsea style it's a
little toned down from the Chelsea we
knew on that So Raven I guess I think I
was wearing like a lot of corduroy back
then but of course of my mom now I'm a
parent right other than being a mom how
is Chelsea changed in the 10 years since
we last saw her I think she's gone
through a lot of life experiences I
think that'll play a little bit into
Chelsea whose last name is different now
and I can't set
if you want to borrow anything rice
you're more than whoa you know I would I
just don't think okay okay no worries no
worries um we can do a costume fitting
or something